MAKE A FEW COMMENTS. WITH A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES ON ON
THEIR- MIKE'S WHEN THEY SPEAK.
I WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO EXPLAIN THE
PROCESS THESE WE'VE DEVELOPED
TO CONTINUE OUR CENTRAL WORK
DURING THE PANDA FOR THOSE OF
YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS SAYS.
FOR ME WE YOUR THAT'S WHAT
WOULD AGAIN FOR THE WHO MAY BE
TO FOR THE FIRST TIME. SOME TO
OF THE TECHNICAL BUT IF THEY
FOR THE- I AMHERST. NINETY
URGENCY TO THE HEALTH SENATE'S
WE MUST LIVE NANA'S GAS SAID TO
SEARCH DISTANCE INCOME WITH AND
LOCAL ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS IS SET HEARING WE
HAVE MADE NECESSARY OBJECT
NORMAL. THIS IN TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS. OR LET
IMPROPER CONDUCTING THE HEARING
IN A WAY. THE HEALTH IN THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC IN OUR
EMPLOYEES. HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE CAPITAL
WITH ONE OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR BATES PARTICIPATING. I
IN THE HEARING REMOTELY WITH
USE OF VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM.
AND I KNOW BY NOW SENATOR BATES
IS MORE FAMILIAR THAN MOST OF
US WITH THE NEW TECHNOLOGY SO
IT'S A REMINDER TO HER AGAIN TO
MEET HER PHONE OR COMPUTER. AT
ANY TIME. HAVE A CALM SENATOR
OP IS THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURING PROGRAM. AND EACH
TIME YOU'RE A KNOWLEDGE TO
SPEAK. A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO USE PLEASE SELECT A NHI<c.cyan></c>
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. I
TEACH AND I WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON YOU DONE IT. SINCE WERE TO
SO IT'S A GOOD REMINDER SENT
BETA. ALL THE I WILL GIVE YOU
HAVE IT HE I STAFF MEMBERS WITH
YOU. IN THE- AND IF YOU DO PAY
THE NAME OF THAT STAFF MEMBER
TO US PUBLIC I WILL ASK IN A
MOMENT I WANTED YOU TO BE.
HEARD TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS. EXCUSE ME WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DE
REQUIRED ALLOW. WE WERE BE
USING A TELE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE POSTED ORDER
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN.
TODAY'S PARTICIPATE NOT IS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE ONE SEVEN SEVEN. NINE TWO.
THE NUMBER AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR THE ACCESS CODE ONE ONE
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO WHEN WE MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WILL A YOU INTO OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MADE. IT
PLEASE KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY FONG.
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND THANK
YOU WITH FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL A DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING IS BECAUSE- ANY IN THE
WHO WERE. MAY BE FROM THE
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT IS EIGHT TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG I'M FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO OUR
NEW ONLINE TOOL. SO AGAIN BE
PATIENT SO WE ALL HER. AND THEN
ON BEHALF OF OUR STATE NOT. I
KNOW WHO IS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY- I ASK THAT ALL
SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. SO BEFORE WE START
THE AGENDA HEY ARE WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND OF
COURSE MEMBERS TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON FOR ROLL CALL
EVERY TIME YOU VOTE MEANT
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MINING MONNING HERE ROTH
YOUR ROTH HERE WILL PRESENT
WILL COMPRISE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE AND AGAIN AS I
NOTED SENATOR BASIS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FROM HER
DISTRICT OFFICE HEY IT WILL BE
PART IN CON QUITE A BAY BUT IS
USING TO VOTE WE'RE- US SENATOR
BATES DO YOU HAVE A- GIVE US.
WITH YOU THE- A- YES I WITH ME
MY JUST DIRECT I YOUR TO GET IN
THE SCREEN LIMIT HELLO YEAH WHY
AGAIN AND WE ARE HERE IN I
GUESS OFFICE IN LOOKING TO GET
CENTER BAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
START GET A BACK AFTER HOUSE.
YEAH YES. WHERE IS THE TAKE A
MAN I. THAT MIGHT HAVE WORKED
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AND WE'RE GONNA START
WITH MS KIMBERLY MCCAULEY WAIT
J. D. DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING I WANT TO
SAY WELCOME TO YOU DIRECTOR
MCCOY WAIT- OFFER YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY. IS WITH YOU- AND
THEN GIVE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS- THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE IT AFTER YOU DO THAT WE
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS IT
THAT'S WHY THAT. SAY WELCOME.
THANK YOU CENTER. I AM VERY
MUCH ONE INTERVIEW WITH PEOPLE
HERE WITH ME IN PERSON AND
VIRTUALLY BOTH MY SPOUSE
CHILDREN ARE HERE OF COURSE
MAKE ALL THIS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STREAMING
YOUR MANAGER OF MY FAMILY TO BE
HERE FROM THE COUNTRY
PARTICULARLY MY PARENTS WHO
HAVE A LONG TIME A PUBLIC IN
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND WHO HAVE
MADE A REALLY SMALL FOR ME TO
HEAR TODAY SO THANK MARK
ALLOWING THAT FOR SAYS WHICH IS.
I'M DELIGHTED TO BE HEARD I
HAVE THIS COME. ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNE AND INDEED THE- FACED
US AS WE TRIED. AGING AND CAL.
IT IS OF COURSE A TIME OF GREAT
CHALLENGE WITH CONDEMNING. MY
MAIN INTEREST IS SYSTEM RACISM
CALLING TO DO MORE AND TO
BETTER. THANK YOU FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT
TO MASTER PLAN ON AGING WE ARE
ON COURSE TO DO SO AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS OUR
DIALOGUE TODAY ABOUT HOW WE GET
THERE TOGETHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M TO IN AND
START CENTER IT'S OUR REMOTE
SEE IF YOU COMMENTS IN. I THINK
I KNOW. ONE MOMENT WE ARE NOT
HEARING SENATOR BATES PHONE ARE
YOU HEARING ME NOW I HEAR YOU
NOW. I THOUGHT YOU SAID I HAVE
TO STAY NOW MISS PROTANDIM
NEARLY IDEA SO ON THE MUTINY.
BAD TRIED YOU THINK YOU. AND
WANT TO SAY GREAT SAY TO THIS
CALL. REYES FOR I HAVE. A
JOINING AND THE VERY AND NOT
AREA. THE AGING OF MARK. WE
HAVE A VERY. GOOD COMP. THE
OTHER DAY ON THE THANK YOU SO
MUCH WAS A VERY LIVE. ALL OF
THE ISSUES I HAVE HAVING WITH
SENIOR FOR MANY SIZE THAT THAT
I IN AND SENIOR THAT WE MAY
DOING NOW. FOR OLD TO YEARS
MORE I HAD TO GO THE YEAR. THAT
I DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY. AS
MUCH OF. YOU ON YEAH. SHE IN
PARTICULAR. OR IN THIS SIZE
THREE NINE WEEKS SO. TO LOOK AT
THE PRESS IN THE FEW. FOR OUR
SENIOR COPY. WE SHE THE VERY
BASS CONGRATULATE YOU. I AM PRO
TEM IN LET ME OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS TO DIRECTOR
MCCOY WAYNE IN. SHE XIN FOR
HER- OF SERVICE WE ALSO HAD A
VERY GOOD CONVERSATION I
LEARNED A LOT FROM THAT ABOUT
CURRENT PRIORITY SINCE
CONSCIOUS AND- MAYBE MIKE I
GUESS IT JUST BE TO ASK YOU TO.
TRY THIS THANKFULLY SHARE SOME
OF. THE INTERSECTION OF CO TEEN
CHALLENGE THIS WAS SOME OF THE
ONGOING SERVICES THE FOR
SENIORS PARTICULARLY- WITH THE
BATH AND- OTHER GRANTS HOW
THAT'S BEING HANDLED. LET ME
START THERE THANK YOU. CENTER
MINING AND INDEED ARE MAKING IT
POSSIBLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO AGE IN THE HOMES THAT WE
CHOOSE WITH THE HELP THAT WE
CHOOSE HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
NATION'S MASS. AND WITH A VENN.
OLDER ADULTS IN OTHER WITH
UNDERLYING CAN. TO AT. THE NEED
FOR. GOOD HOMES FIRST SUPPORT
AT HOME. AND ATTENTION TO THAT
CONNECTION HAS BECOME EVEN MORE
URGENT SO WE ARE- WORKING ON
ISOLATION INITIATIVE FOR
WORKING ON NUTRITION
INITIATIVES. HE SAID OUR HOME.
HEALTH SUPPORTS PARTICULARLY
SEA BASS COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES ADULT SERVICES AND
M. S. S. P. MULTI PURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAMS ARE
ESSENTIAL THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE. SERVICE READ. YEAH TELL
HEALTH AND DOOR STOP AND DRIVE
ALIVE AND LOOK KIND OF RAPPER
SERVICES TO KEEP PEOPLE
CONNECTED AND HEALTHY AND AT
HOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- I
THANK MY FINAL QUESTION WOULD
BE BOTH JUST TO ASK YOU TO
SHARE A LITTLE OF YOUR VISION
OF HOW WE ADDRESS CULTURAL
CHANGES TO SO MANY MORE PEOPLE
ENTERING THE RANK OF SENIOR
CLASS STEP. IN KIND OF IT MR
WHICH IS OUR CULTURE I YOU SOME.
GOOD THOUGHTS AND COMMITMENT ON
THAT FRONT- IF YOU COULD JUST
ADDRESS THAT AND THEN ALSO THE
PLATES PROGRAM WHEN CHINA WAS A
FEATURE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
RESPONSE IN. LEGISLATOR TO SEE
THE IMPACT ON RESTAURANTS IN.
FOLK SHELTERING IN PLACE AND I
THINK IT'S YOUR DEPARTMENT THAT
THAT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED SO
MAYBE JUST. A LITTLE UPDATE ON
THAT- AND AGAIN I THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY FOR YEAR SERVICE
EVERY DAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR YES THE RIGHT EIGHT IS
CHANGED THAT IS IT THAT'S A BIG
DRIVER OF THE MASTER PLAN AGING
BE TAKE OKAY THE WAY. THAT
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE AGING AND
DIVERSIFYING AT THE AGE AND-
HOW DID I. WHAT IT MEANS A-
THIS MORNING WE HAVE OUR FIRST
EVER TO HALL ON AGES AND IT ANY.
ATTENDED BY HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
FROM AROUND THE STATE REALLY
COMMITTED TO A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL AGES AND IT WILL TAKE THAT
AWARENESS THAT EDUCATION-
AROUND INCLUSION HOW DO WE HAVE
HOLDEN CHEN WORKPLACES IN MALTA
GENERAL NO HOUSING CENTERS AND
REALLY HAVE LITTLE COMMUNITIES
WORK HERE ALL AND A YEAR OLD.
CORD TO THE VISION OF THE MAP.
EIGHT YES THE PERMANENT AGING
HAS A LONG TRADITION IN
NUTRITION MANY OF YOU KNOW OUR-
MEALS PROGRAM SOMETIMES MEALS
ON WHEELS AND CONGREGATE MEALS
AT SENIOR CENTERS THAT AGAIN
REDESIGN REINVENT TO DELIVERY
AND PICK UP IN THE CODE PUBLIC
BORDERS WE WERE VERY PLEASED TO
PARTNER WITH OUR EIGHT. THIS IS.
I WANTED IT TO HAVE A WAY WIN
PRO OF THE DELIVERY MEALS TO
OLDER ADULTS AND APARTMENT
LOCAL RESTAURANTS TO HELP GIVE
THAT ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND HELP
FOLKS GET BACK TO WORK AND KEEP
THOSE BUSINESSES AND- LEARN FOR
HER GRANDMA'S THE FIRST OF MANY.
BUT ONE THING WE KNOW FOR SURE
IS THAT WIN WIN. OF THE FAMILY
IN THE HOUSE AND THE LOCAL
BUSINESS HAS BEEN BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT FOR BOTH SIDES. AND
THAT THE NEED CONTINUES WE ARE
SEEING OUT RECORD INCREASE IN
ALL OF OUR MEALS PROGRAMS BY
OLDER ADULTS WHETHER IT'S- THE
MEALS ON WHEELS TO CONGREGATE
FEEDING THE GREAT PLATE. HEALTH
RASH. MALES AND SO WE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HELP CONTINUE TO
MEET THOSE NEEDS WHILE ALSO
REDUCING THAT NEED GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT DIRECTOR AND
ACTUALLY CENTER MONEY PASS THE
THAT I WAS MOST INTERESTED
INSIDE AND I WAS SATISFIED WITH
THAT IN AT THE PROPER TIME I'D
LIKE TO MOVE YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU IN. RUN I SENATOR
ROTH EVEN PRO TEM A ACTUALLY NO
QUESTIONS CONGRATULATIONS. WELL
THANK YOU. OKAY I THINK WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO DO NOW IS GO TO
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. A. N. OF COURSE A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES WISHING
TO COMMENT TO BE A FOR THAT TO
SPIT POLL FREE NOW. IS FOUR
NINE ONE SIX THREE. FOUR ACCESS
CO. ONE ONE SEVEN SEVEN TWO
NINE TWO- LET ME JUST START
WITH WITNESSES IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE HE WON. I SEE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE BUT TO ENSURE
THAT WERE- COVERED ALL THE
BASES LET ME JUST DOUBLE CHECK
AND SEE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH TO TELL.
IN SUPPORT. I SO WE ARE GOING
TO GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE AND
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY ON
THEIR END THERE IS A MODERATOR
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
AND INTRODUCE RIGHT NOW TO PROP
AND WAITING TO BUY IN FORT.
OINTMENT AND T. SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN BERYL
AGAIN AND THIS IS TO SHOW
SUPPORT IF YOUR AND MAKE YOU
FEEL AND YOU WANT TO OPPOSE.
ONE GIRL ACCESS. I GET A FIFTY
CHAU SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEIR OWN NOW. AND I WAS
LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT AN AND LIKE
YOU OKAY THANK YOU META
MODERATOR BEFORE WE GO TO THE
FIRST WITNESS I JUST WANT TO
REMIND. PEOPLE TESTED THANK
THIS HELLO AND EARLY FOR OUR
STENOGRAPHER SO THAT WE CAN BE
SURE AND GET YOUR- COMMENTS SO.
AT A MODERATE THE FIRST WITNESS.
FIRST OF ALL TIMELINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. QUITE SURE
MEMBERS FOR THIS IS KATHY
MOSSBERG ON BEHALF OF MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA CAN YOU TO
CONFIRM IF THE LATEST DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE SOMEONE WITH
MORE PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
RELEVANT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
ROLE AND MISS MCCOY WEIGHED
ONLY WILL. REAR NOW PROP. I'M
AND THEN FOR NUMEROUS WE AD TO
CALL SO SERVICE FOR YOUR SPACE
CAN THE BLOOD THE BRANCH AFTER
THAT THE CALIFORNIA DEVELOPMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES NUMBER YEARS
PRIOR TO HER APPOINTMENT TO GDA
LAST. NIGHT SHE HELPED THE.
SIGNIFICANT LEADERSHIP
THROUGHOUT THE OUT OF THE SITE
OUT. SHE ALSO ORGANIZE THE CAL
BRANCH TO INCREASE. IN PDF THAT
SPONSORED THEIR AND TO
FACILITATE PHILIPPINES MAIN
GATE AMONG STATE OFF UNDER.
ROLE REMOTE AREAS. OF DISASTER
IN CRISIS SHE IN PARTICULAR.
AND DID AND HELPFUL APPROACH TO
PARTNER WITH HOLDERS. AND
ENGAGE ALL STAKEHOLDERS DURING
A CRY. HAS BEEN EDITING IN OUR
DEAL WITH HER THE WOULD NINETY
HAVE DONE. THE DEMAND FOR YOUR
BROUGH HASN'T BY. SENIOR
POVERTY AND YOUR HUNGER. AND
KEEP TROUBLED TO ON THE ISSUES
FOR A LONG BUT COMING AFTER
BROUGHT HIGH TO THE WHICH YOU
COULD NOT BETTER. TO WAR WITH
THAN MISS MCCOY WAIT TO WORK
WITH A- ALL THESE. THE REASON
WE ARE CONFIRMATION TODAY HER
DRESS THANK YOU THANK YOU AMBER
FOR WE GO TO THE NEXT WHICH I
JUST WANT LET OUR STENOGRAPHER
I KNOW I SEE YOU ON THIS IF FOR
ANY RIGHT YOU NEED PEOPLE TO
ADAPT I BE WATCHING IF YOU
MOTION ME DO THAT ARE A MATTER
GREATER NEXT. SURE MAX. BY
EIGHTEEN PRETTY FAR HAD. CAM
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SAYS MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
WE TO STAND STRONG SUPPORTER
CAMAGUEY WAGE OINTMENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF A IN I'VE HAD THE-
BEING A PRESS. I AM FOR MORE
THAN FIFTEEN SHE IS OF THE MOST
GEN ONE AND- TALENTED ADVOCATES
AND- FOR LOW INCOME FOLKS
SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- AND- SHE HAS A
LONG TRACK RECORD OF. COME
PEOPLE TO TOGETHER TO GET
THINGS DONE I THINK WHAT THIS
MOSSBERG JUST MENTIONED ABOUT
HER ROLE IN BEING TO FINALLY
AFTER SOME FORTY YEAR WHILE
WE'RE- OF PASSED ARE. TO BE
ABLE TO PULL OFF FOR A IS IT
UNDERSCORES BILL TO DO THE
MAMMOTH. THAT IS IN YOUR HALF
OF THOSE. CALIPHATE GETTING CAL
AS FOR THE FIRST TIME AND THANK
GOD THAT HAPPENED IN ADVANCE
WITH. SO THAT. IT ARE GETTING.
IN THAT THEY NEED AND CAN
DESERVES CREDIT FOR THAT WE
HAVE NO DE THAT. CD OUR CURRENT
DO AT DEPARTMENT THE AND WE
STRONG STAND IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. MAX LEVEL CAROLINA
LEVIN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
NUMBER TEN THE NUMBERS THE
CADENCES INTERCHANGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS IN THE CALIFORNIA
TRUSTS CYCLE ISSHIN. I THANK
THE SENATE. DEMOCRATIC FOR
CONCERTS PRIOR THE NEEDS OF
OLDER ADULTS INCLUDING RELATED
TO POVERTY FOOD ASSISTANCE AND
THAT'S A TIE- GOING OUT TO
MYSELF WITH IT BUT MADE BY BOTH
THIS MONSTER AGAIN MR HERALD.
THAT CALIFORNIA COULDN'T FOR A
BETTER LEADER THAN MS MCCOY
WILL. JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW
UNDERSCORE THE CITY
ACCOMPLISHED. IN TERMS OF A SIX
IMPLEMENTATION OF EXPANSION OF
CALVET. DECIDE CONSUMERS.
RIDLEY DAMAGE. YEAH NO. IN
HIGHER SOLELY WITH. THE LARGEST
ADVANCES AND THE- COULD TAKE
NEXT GENERATION AND JUST IN
TIME THIS IS OUR HEALTH TO I
WOULD WANT THE SENATE AND
DEPARTMENT OF A NO THAT THE
CALPERS EXTENSION AND HOLD
HARMLESS. AND CELEBRATED AROUND
THE TREE THERE REALLY SHOWING
IN KIM'S WORK IN ON ALL OF THE
WEAPONS COUNTY IN THAT LIGHT.
BEATEN UP TRAIT THAT CONTINUED
IN HER TENURE AN AGING PROGRAMS
BEEN MARK THAN A TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OLDER TO WRINKLE THE
NINETEEN AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT
HER COME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WAY. LED SEVERAL
SIGNIFICAN INITIATIVES IN OUR
PREVIOUS ROLES THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. AND HER
LEADERSHIP ON THE MASTER PLAN
FOR EIGHTEEN IN PARTICULAR HAS
BEEN IMPRESSIVE. I USUALLY
DEMONSTRATED INNOVATIVE
THINKING IN A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH TO ENSURE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- HEARD. A DIRECT.
I AM QUITE AWARE ME IS THE
RIGHT LEADER FOR THIS TIME FOR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO CALL HER NOMINATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NOT A LOT TO LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
CARILLO WE CAN HEAR YOU. ALL
WONDERFUL MY NAME IS JEFFREY
CARDIO I AN ADVOCATE- I
RECOMMEND THROUGH YOUR SYSTEM
WAYS I HAVE WORKED WITH HER AS
YOU SAY IN THE PAST TWO YEARS
AND SEEN HER DEMONSTRATE
CHALLENGE THE BILL EVERY.
MAZING WHAT SHE HAS I PROBABLY
YOU DON'T CARE ENOUGH TO WHAT
SHE IS DOING AND THE TIME IT.
BUT FROM. WE HOPE IN. THE
CALIFORNIA FOR SS COOL HARD
INDOORS HER AND THERE IS A
NUMBER OF OTHER COALITIONS
YOU'LL BE SHE IS THE PERSON AND
THE CAP OVER ONE WITH. THE
REASON WHY I DIDN'T THE MORNING
ON THE EIGHTH BUT SHE'S GOT SO
MANY CONFIRMED OVER THERE BUT
SOME. BUT SHE GETS ANY FOR AT
ALL IN THE EFFORT TO IS BUT
HARDLY SUPPORT AND ENDORSE
ISN'T BUT THE- WELL SPOKEN AND
OF OUR- AND IF YOU YOU ALSO. I
MORE WITH HER THE NEXT WITH YOU
WHAT DO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NECK WITH THIS. BACK
TO A LOT LINE TWENTY PLEASE
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PRO
TEM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I MEAN THE LEAK BINA
MONDAY OF UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS ASK ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN. PROVIDERS
PROVIDING CARE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE. IT'S BEEN INVALUABLE I'M
FOR THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
PROCESS AND WE KNOW THAT SHE
WILL BE A TREMENDOUS ASSET
CONTINUING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BACK TWELVE AUTO LINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU SENATOR SO THIS
OPPORTUNITY NAME AND THE CALL
AND BE DIRECTOR FOR CALCULUS.
THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
ABOUT. THE WHOLE HEARTED I FOR
YOUR RECORD GATE YOU'RE ON
CAN'T WAIT. THE TWO TO TRY
DESCRIBE FISCAL. IT HARD IT
SOUNDS. OUR YEAH ENCOURAGE IT
YEAH. ADVOCATE ABSOLUTELY-
SHOULD REFER TO IS THE
ENERGIZER BUNNY BECAUSE SHE ARE.
GET UP AND GOES BACK ACTUALLY
WANT ON ALL OVER WEAKER FUNDING
AND I CAN THINK OF NO GREATER
LEADERSHIP QUALITIES RIGHT NOW
SOMEONE YOU COULD BRING ALL
LOOK AT DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
THE FOLDERS- BUT POSITIVE.
DIRECTION SO MUCH NEGATIVE
GOING ON. THERE'S SO MUCH BEER
THAT ARE ADULT AND NOT AFTER
THAT THANK. EVEN CURRY YOU HAVE
A AT THE HOME BETTER HEARING
THERE IS A POSITIVE BEING WE'LL
FIND A WHITE AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL SO BOB ALONG WITH ALL OF
THE THAT ACROSS THE STATE WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND WHATNOT IN
RESERVATIONS AFTER YOUR-
DOLLARS SPENT. YOU DIRECTOR FOR
WHEN YOU ARE OF THE- CORRECTLY
HOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK WE'RE BEGINNING TO GET A
VERY ACCURATE PICTURE OF
THOUGHT OF- MISTOOK FULLY WAIT.
LET ME ASK- WITNESSES GOING
FORWARD IF YOU WILL- MAYBE CAN
DENTURE COMMENTS A LITTLE BIT
ARE WE WANT TO KNOW WHO YOU ARE
WE WANT TO KNOW THAT YOU
SUPPORT OF PEOPLE OF SAID A LOT
OF GREAT THINGS ABOUT ARE YOU
CAN- AGREE WITH THOSE COMMENTS
OR OUR ASSOCIATE YOURSELF THOSE
COMMENTS BUT IN IN OF TOM. I
BECAUSE WE QUITE A LARGER CHEN
LET ME JUST ASK IF YOU WILL BE
A LITTLE BIT BRIEF AGAIN
APPRECIATE COMMENTS AND ALL ON
IT WAS MORE INFORMATION ON THE
WEB IF YOU'RE- ABLE TO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NECK SURE NOT A
TIMELINE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO BUT CHAIR ATKINS. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS FRED
MAIN REPRESENTING CAL PAYS. A
WHITE ASSOCIATION OF PROGRAMS
FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY THE PROVIDE INTEGRATED
HEALTH CARE FOR FRAIL SENIORS
FIFTY FIVE YEARS AND OLDER AND
WE JUST WANT TO ENDORSE A
CHEMICAL A WAY COOL OR- THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU
MISTER. HELLO THIS IS KAREN K.
FOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WE
SUPPORTED THE LATTER. AND WE
HAVE. A LOT. YEAH AND- OF HER
CONFIRMATION AN URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NOT A LOT TO LINE TEN
WE'VE GOT HAD. THAT IN TURN
NUMBERS MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF
OF ALZHEIMER'S. LOS ANGELES.
MONEY AND- BE A GALLON THE CORE
WE PARTNER AND REALLY JUST
TODAY SHE AND TACTIC WORK WITH
FROM DAY ONE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR KNOWLEDGE.
THANK THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NOT A LOT THANK. WE'VE GOT.
HELLO THIS TOPIC OF OUR ON THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE
MIKE HERALD I'M CALLING AS A
RECOMMEND. FOR THE DEATH.
APPOINTMENT HAVING WORKED A
LONG AND SOMETIMES FOR. THE
CLAY WAIT OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS I CAN TELL YOU THAT SHE
IS THE LEADER WHO IS BACK WHO
SUPPORT OTHER WOMEN. I AM AND-
HER THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
WITNESS. MAC THE LOCAL TO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF WAITING
AGE CALIFORNIA AT WE URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONFIRM IF NOT
QUITE WAIT OUT THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. WORKED ON A WHITE THANK.
YOUR PLAN FOR AND HOPE. SHARES
ALL THE DEFENSE EIGHT ALL THE
KIND OUT OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT
THAN PREVIOUSLY STATED AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED.
WORKING OUT WE- THANK YOU NOT.
AND AT THE MOMENT WE HAVE NO
ONE UP THANK YOU BAD VERY
MINDER YOU DO WHAT ARE YOU THE
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. SHOW
SUPPORT. I'M AND THEN THEY'RE
ALL. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE LIKE
YOU MADE A MODERATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH WILL BE. IF YOU IN A
MALL. OUT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO.
IN OPPOSITION APPOINTMENT WILL
START HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
ONE AND THERE ARE NO- MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK IN. LET
ME JUST CHECK OUT ROOM ONE.
SEATING NOW ONE THING FORWARD
OUT MADAME MODERATOR I'M COMING
BACK TO YOU FOR OUR WITNESSES
WAITING TO TEST VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. AND IF
YOU WISH TO A POLE PLEASE PRESS
THE WIND AND THEIR OWN NOW
AGAIN TO UPHOLD PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOT. AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE KILL.
OKAY META MODERATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH ARE WE WILL BRING IT
BACK HERE AND- NOT SURPRISED TO
HEAR NO ONE OPPOSITION THE
SUPPORT COMMENTS WE MISSED YOUR
MAN I THINK YOU ALREADY THE
CARD FOR THANK. I KNOW LAUREL.
MINING I AYE ROTH ALRIGHT ROTH
AYE LOOP WILK HI LOOK AYE
ATKINS ATKINS AYE THEN SORRY
THANK YOU SIR SIGNATURE THAT IS
FOUR ZERO WITH. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE AS A
PARTNER SO GRATEFUL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
OFFER. OKAY WE GET THE GO AHEAD
TO THE NEXT- GROUP OF
APPOINTMENTS AND PROBABLY AFTER
THAT WE WILL TAKE A LITTLE BIT
OF A BREAK. UP THIS TO. BURNING
WE WILL NOW TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. WE HAVE WITH US
THOMAS F. STEAM JD MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS
HAVE ALSO OF FELICIA ESCOBAR
KERR EIGHTY ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS WE HAVE
DARK A MONTH ARE. THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. WELCOME TO ALL THREE
OF YOU AND- WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND START WITH. OPENING
COMMENTS AND- WE WILL START
WITH YOU- MISTER ABSTAINED AND-
THEN PROCEED TO MISS ESCOBAR
CARILLO AND THEN DR- TELLS OUR
AND LET EACH OF YOU MAY. RITA I
WANT THE FEW BILL. COMPELLED TO
DO SO AND THEN WE WILL GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ARE
COMMON AND QUESTIONS AND THE
SITE THANK YOU SENATOR MINING I
AM QUITE AWARE THAT MR IT A HAS
BEEN. THE CHAIR OF ACTUALLY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS MORE WHY
YOU'RE GOING TO GO FIRST.
FIFTEEN SO WELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU'RE ACT VICE CHAIR THEM
I MEAN PROCESS. EIGHT THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS REALLY BEEN ONE
OF THE PRIVILEGE THANK TO SERVE
ON THE ANY COLLEGE BOARD. NOW
MUCH EXPERIENCE WITH THAT. SO I
MEAN EFFORTS IS MANY COLLEGES
LIKE AND I'VE BEEN THERE SINCE.
IN MY FIRST THAT AMONG THE
BOARD AND ALL OF THESE MEETINGS
THAT MAP WITH FACULTY PASSED BY
STAFF WRITERS AND OF COURSE
STUDENTS AND FOUND THEM ALL TO
BE X. RATED. OUR AND- IN
REPRESENT ALL HEALTH THEY'RE
ALL A INCOMES RACES AND WALKS
OF LIFE OUR PROGRAMS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BLIX SYMBOL
FOR. PERRANCE SO YOU ARE
SERRATED REALLY. AND THOSE WITH
THIS A- AND THE PEOPLE TO COME
THE STUDENTS TO COME ARE
LOOKING TO GAIN SKILLS WITHOUT
ECONOMIC PLANNER. AND MANY ARE
NOT ALWAYS THE WORKERS AND I
THINK AS YOU ALL KNOW MANY ARE.
HOUSING IN YOUR- ANY COLLEGES
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO ADDRESS
INCOME INEQUALITY. AND DURING
MY TENURE ON THE BOARD I
BELIEVE WE FIRED AN OUT ENDING
CHANCELLOR AND DOBBY STRATEGY
BASED ON STUDENTS LEAVING THE
POLLS ARE FOR AS QUICKLY AS
WELL WITH A VERY. SYSTEMATIC
THAT'S TRIED IT WORKED. SUPPORT
TODAY I'D BE HONORED TO CAN TO
SERVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISS ESCOBAR'S CARILLO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE
COMMUNITY AMBITION CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR FOR YOUR TIME
THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF OF
TAKEN TO GET MY APPOINTMENT I.
THE COMP HE PLACED IT ME I. WE
NEED TO THIS POSITION AND ALSO
A CHANCE TO OPEN UP. AND HIS
TEAM FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT. IN MY ON BOARDING
PROCESS OF. SEVERAL MINDS IT'S
BEEN AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO
GET TO KNOW MY FULL BOARD
MEMBERS INCLUDING THE TWO THAT
ARE WITH US TO. YES LOCALLY
STAFF. AND ALSO NO THE LARGE
AND IMPORTANT COMMUNITY THAT IS
OUR CA COLLEGE FROM. ON IN
MINUTES AND STUDENTS STUDENTS
AND OTHER I COSTS A- SELECT THE
THINK I FINALLY HAVE MOST
IMPORTANT WHAT WE LIKE TO THANK
MY FAMILY ESPECIALLY MY HUSBAND
FRANCE'S CAREER. ON THIS. THIS
IS REALLY A TRANSITION FOR OUR
FAMILY AND I FOUND OUT I WAS
PREGNANT SHORTLY AFTER MEMBERS
FORTY THERE'S A LOT EXACTLY.
FIND THEN WHEN I FOR THIS. I
HAVE I'M TO REPORT THAT WELCOME
PERCENT SIGNED ABLE WELL JUST
OVER TWO MONTHS AGO IN WE ALSO
A CALLER COBBLER IF THE HOUSE
AND WHO KEEPS IS BUSY AND ON
OUR TELL A LOT. I ALSO. IT YOU
HAVE TIME FOR US. RIGHT HERE MY
TO THE BACK AS ALTHOUGH I
TRYING TO GET THEM A TO THE
BEST EASIER NOW I AS A DAUGHTER
OF A WIN FOR THE COLLEGE. WHO
THE FIRST HER FAMILY BRANCH. I
UNDERSTAND TRANSMIT OFFERED
WITH COLLEGES TO THEIR STUDENTS
AND MY WOULD HAVE BEEN GO ON TO
TRANCE BURKE WE ARE HER BA IN
HER DEGREE IN SO WORK. THE
WORKING FAMILIES SHE WHEN BACK.
SHE THEY HE TEACHES AT FEATURES
WORKER AT A YOUR FORTY FOR YOUR
AND IN MY HOME AND ACCESS SO I
THINK MY JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF.
THEIR COLLEGE. GIVE THEM WELL
SINCE THE- IN THE MY HUSBAND
SAID SEVERAL MAY FAMILY HAVE A
ARE COMMUNITY ACROSS AND THEIR
TIME THERE HAD HAVE HAS BEEN
IMPORTANT AND WHAT. THERE LIFE
WAS WHETHER IT'S IN GETTING IN
IT SHOULD NEVER OR BECOME IS
PARK RANGER ON THEY'VE ALL THAT
THE EXPERIENCE THEY'VE HAD ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON. I JUST
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS REFUGEE
AND I GOT USE THIS IS A
COMMUNITY THAT I'VE SPENT MY
REAR WORKING WITH. AN ADVOCATE.
ON IF THERE ARE SOME WORKING
PART OF OUR- OTHER CAN YOU AT
THAT I WOULD BE FOCUS ON YOUR
MY CAN AND ON THE OF GOVERNORS.
I'M FOR THIS YOU MAY MORE I'M
HONORED TO BE. ON THE WATER
LEVEL. ON MY HOPE HOPE IMPROVE.
THE QUALITY THAT. BY TO ALL OUR
TWO POINT TWO MILLION STUDENTS
AND THEIR TEN YEAR HUNDRED SIX
A CALL ACROSS THE STATE AND I
LOOK FORWARD. WORK WITH YOU ALL
I ALLEGED. I'M SO AND PROVIDE.
AND POLICIES THAT IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION RIGHT
FORCE TO ACROSS THE STATE I
FORWARD TO AND ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY AND THINK SO MUCH FOR
THE OP TO BE WAIT THANK. THANK
YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE CAN. THEY WILL GO MY
COLLIE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION MY APPOINTMENT TO
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS I'M
SORRY I DO THINK THE COMMITTEE
OF HER FOR. IN THE WAY I WOULD
LIKE TO- DOCTOR DOCTORS HOLD
BUT MY THE STAFF FOR TORONTO I
WHY ARE WE DIDN'T HAVE YOU ONCE
IT. TO MAKE SURE THE WE HAD YOU
ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
ON MUTED. WE CAN HEAR ME NOW
YEAH WE CAN WE CAN SEE YOU
WHICH IS WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
DO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AGAIN
I AM ON THE CELLS ARE AND IF TO
THINK THEY CAN FOR YOUR- OF MY
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR THE
GOVERNOR. I AM GLAD HONORED DO
YOU HAVE BEEN A POINT. THEY
NEED TO ENSURE THAT. WE ARE
PROVIDING THE ADEQUATE. AND
INSURING THAT ARE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE WORKING TOWARDS
SHE CHEATING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES. SO FOR TO HAVE
AMAZING LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT
FROM THE CHANCE OFFICE WE-
TAKEN ON THIS LEADERSHIP ROLE-
I'M A TRULY AMAZING THAT THE
WORK THAT IS BEING. ACCOMPLISH
GETTING ALL THE CHALLENGES WE-
THIS YEAR- I TRULY BELIEVE AND
HAVE SPENT MY CAREER ADVOCATING
FOR. INSURING THAT- ARE YOUNG
ADULTS HAVE ACCESS TO ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL MOBILITY IN THE
STATE. REALLY BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE THE LYNCHPIN TO ENSURING
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING. GETTING THEIR
DEGREE OTHER THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR CERTIFICATE- THAT THEY'RE
GETTING ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT. THEY CONTINUE TO BE
ECONOMICALLY SOLVENT I. CAN
REALLY MEET THEIR EDUCATIONAL
HEALTH PLEASE- I CAN TRULY
HONORED FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THINK. AND
I GOT. THANK WANT TO THINK OF
MY PARENTS WHO EMIGRATED IN
THIS COUNTRY MORE THAN. TWO
YEARS AGO AND HAVE GIVEN US.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS THE
AMERICAN DREAM. ART OF THAT HAS
BEEN. ACCESS TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
ALL THE SACRIFICES THAT THEY
NEED TO ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS THE OPERA.
I ALSO LIKE TO STATE THANK YOU.
SPENDING SO THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE PROCESS AND OUR SIX YEAR
OLD. YOU NEED TO BE A
PROPONENTS OF IN INSURING THAT
THE SYSTEM CONTINUES IN ME THE
DESIRED EXPECTATIONS AND I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT WE RIGHT
PAST- LEADERSHIP. LEAVE THE
ORGAN. AS WELL AS- DIVISION FOR
SUCCESS THAT WE'VE LAID OUT TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
KIND TO ME. RIGHT NOW COME IN
THOSE AND THE STUDENTS THAT WE
SERVE ON SOMETHING YOU AGAIN I
TRULY APPRECIATE YOU AND
GAUGING THE DIALOGUE ON LOOK
FORWARD TO YEAH. DID YOU. IS UP
A DOCTOR ALSO I'M GONNA GO TO
US BAYH FOR AND SENATOR BAYH TO
YOU HAVE COMMON AND QUESTION.
BUT IT FILM TO WITH THE OF INTO
ARE LET US KNOW IF WANT TO BE A
QUESTION ALL. THREE THREE. SO I
WILL I THINK ON A HAVE TO CALL
OF COVER A COUPLE AREAS AND-
HOW. IT WOULD. ON AN ANSWER OR
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS OR
INDIVIDUALLY AND JOE AFTER YEAR
AND FOR OF ALL I'M NOT TO SAY.
I KNOW SUPER CHAMPION OF OUR
COMMUNITY THE- WHAT. IN
CERTAINLY HELP ME WITH MY AGE
AND I THINK PROBABLY MOST
IMPORTANT HELPED MY FAMILY
BECAUSE I WENT YOU KNOW A YEAR
THAT I OF WITH WHAT. ABROAD I
COLLEGE BROUGHT IN THE CAME
BACK AND THEN THE UNITS ALL FOR
TO GO AHEAD. SO OFF I WENT TO
COMMUNITY ENGINE WAS A TO MAKE
UP TO RISK. ONE ANSWER THANK.
AND GOT GRAY. YEAH YEAH I NEED
TO GET TO WORK RIGHT AWAY IN I
HAVE PROVIDE THOSE TOOLS WILL
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE YOU KNOW
EXTRA IN. EDUCATION COUPLE
QUESTIONS. REGARDING THE
DISTANCE ABOUT THERE ARE STATE
ALL OF THE JUST WHY TO MAKE.
THAT WE ARE PAYING ATTENTION
TO. OF THE REED IS A IT ME BOB.
MORE RESOURCES THAT ONLINE HD
OR THE DISTANCE. IN PARTICULAR
INTERNET ACCESS AND HAVING THE
TOOLS HARPER THEIR STUDENTS HE-
I THE UNDERSTOOD AREA. YEAH
OKAY THAT'S WHEN. THE ONLINE ON
MY NEED TO THAT IS NEEDING
STAND NEED FOR I'M MOVING ON TO
YOU KNOW FOR YOUR CALL AND READ
FORCE. AND ABOUT THE FOR
DEVELOP ISSUE OUT WE COME TO. I
WITH OUR MANY BUSINESS CLOSE
LOSING YOUR WE'LL ARE YOU ALL
FEEL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS GOING
TO BE IN THE- TO HELP WITH THE
REAR. THAT MIGHT BE NEED OUT.
BECAUSE SO THAT THEY CAN READ
ENSURE WORKFORCE WITH NEW SKILL
OR MEETING PROBABLY. WHAT WILL
BE THE MAYBE THE NEW NORMAL IN
TERMS OF LAW WHERE THE JOBS ARE
SO NOW. BRUSH CHILD. AND LET ME
ASK YOU IF YOU WANNA TACKLE
THAT FIRST AS I REMIND EACH OF
YOU THAT YOU CAN DO YOUR REYES
IF YOU WANNA. NEITHER YOUR HAND
AND I COULD SEE YOU ARE YOU CAN
USE THE RIGHT HAND REYES
FUNCTION ON THE COMPUTER. CHIP
AND YOU ARE US OFF THE- THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU- SENATOR
BASE FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I WE HAVE
BEEN VERY OUR- AS TRYING TO
PRESS THIS CRISIS- AT THE WHEN
IT FIRST BEGAN ON MARCH SIX YOU
BETTER BOARD MEET ABLE CANCELAR
PARTY TO. SINCE HE- THAT JUST
MAKE THIS ONLINE EDUCATION HI
HANNAH TEAM EMPLOY OF OUT
ACTIVITIES THAT THAT IN I'LL
JUST. A NEW PRO NEW TRAIN AND-
AND SOFTWARE THEY COULD HAVE
THEM DO A BETTER BACK IN WE
THINK THAT SUCCESSFUL I'M- YEAH.
SORRY SO WHERE THERE TENDED BY
MORE THE A SAN MEMBERS OF THE
CALLER SYSTEM TO WRITE ABOUT
THEY BE DOING TO HELP IMPROVE
MAKE SURE THERE'S AN ALL ALL.
THIS CONTINUED THROUGHOUT SAYS
IN TERMS OF BROADBAND ACCESS
AND ISIS. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
LOOK HELLO HELLO BIT WITHOUT
THROUGH OUR FOUNDATION FOR
COMMUNITY AND I THE COUNTY
SHOULD WHICH WAS OF COURSE A
COMPLETE ONLINE COLLEGE. HAD A-
THE IS SOME. RURAL AND NEEDY
COLLEGES- THAT OBVIOUSLY WASN'T
ENOUGH FOR EVERYONE BUT BUT IT
WAS SOMEHOW SO. CONTINUE TO BE
VIGILANT ON THAT UP HI AM VERY
STRONG FOR ON AND UNIVERSAL
BROADBAND HOPE THAT CAN. BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN ALLEGE. TIMES I
MEAN AS I LOOKED IN THIS. I'M
YOU KNOW I RIVER I'VE
DISCOVERED THAT. I'VE BEEN
EXIST IN SOME CITIES THE. THAT
AND OTHER PEOPLE OR TO BUY IT
SO WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THAT
AS I JUST TO BUILD A. FOR HEY
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I ANYONE
ELSE WANT TO CALM. THIS IS FOR
YEAH I WOULD JUST ALL SAY YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT THIS IS THE
QUESTION OF IS REALLY IN AND
ALL. A TRAINING FOR FACULTY ARE
TO AND TO UNDER HOW BEST TO USE
TECHNOLOGY FOR ALL I THINK
EXPERIENCING IS WHEN A NEW NEW
FACE RIGHT OF OUR AS WE THINK.
CATION BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE YOU
KNOW ONE ON ONE SESSIONS THAT
MAYBE IN THE PAST. PROFESSORS
WHO PROVIDE. HOURS BUT RIGHT
NOW THAT'S ONE OF SO THERE HAS
TO BE AWAY FOR THOSE STUDENTS
STATE FACE. I'M SUPPORT.
CORRECT FROM THERE I. WILL T.
OR ITS SOME OF THE STEAM
SUPPORTS CENTER I THINK THAT'S
ALSO SOME THAT NEED BEEN
WORKING HERE TECHNOLOGY. TO
BACK PROCESS. PEOPLE STAY IN
SCHOOL I'M AND STEPPED IT WHEN
IT GET COMP AND HARD GIVEN THE
ARMOR. THANK YOU. DOCTOR SO ARE.
MUCH MORE ANYTHING BOTH AND
NINE AND I'M COLLEAGUES WILL
HAVE TOUCHED UPON THE WAY THAT.
THE CHANCE OF OFFICE PROVIDED
CONTINUOUS TO THE HIGH. TIME I
WOULD ALSO ADD I KNOW THAT THEY
ALSO SENT OUT TO EXPERTS TO
COLLEGE. I DID I'M- THERE
RESOURCES THAT TO DATA THE
WEEKLY WEB ON ALL ONLINE OKAY
SIGNED THAT ARE COLLEGES ARE
SUCCESS NEED OF THE SYSTEM I
KNOW WE'RE PROVIDING ADEQUATE
WELL. TO OUR STUDENTS AS WE
CONTINUE TO. THIS CURRENT AND-
THANK YOU SENATOR BAYH. THANK
YOU ARE COVERED YOU COVERED A
AND I YOU A LOT TO COVER
SOMETHING YOU I AND AGAIN YOU
SO MUCH FOR SERVICE KIND. ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT STAND WE ON
ADULT WHERE I WILL SUPPORT. THE
WORK OF HER NATION THANKS AGAIN
FOR YOUR- THANK THIRD RIGHT I'M
GONNA I CENTER ON TO GO ON I
KNOW I YOU WHEN I GO IN OFFICE
DIRECTIONS IN THE OVEN THAT WE
LIEU SENATOR. I WANT TO LET YOU
GO AHEAD AND GO RIGHT I IN I
DON'T KNOW ANYBODY ELSE HAS TO
LEAVE FOR I DO WANNA. GET IN
HIS BEFORE. THANK YOU MADAM TEM
IN A WANT MAKE. IN SOME X. TO
SERVICE HAVING EFFORT TO THE
FIFTY OF OUR COLLEGES. I THINK
REALLY DAM AND SOME ABOUT THE
CALL OF I DON'T KNOW THE- OFF
TWO A DAY THIS BUT I HAD REAL.
TIONS WITH ALL OF WEEKS ARRAY
OF FROM CAL TO FUNDING FORMULA
BUT IN LIGHT OF THE- SOME COURT
JUST NINE DOT. WE KNOW THAT. IF
PROVIDES. SOME OPEN BUT STILL
NOT. RELIEF IF ANY OF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS BRIEFLY- HELLO
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IS ACCOMMODATING
DARKEST AND WHAT IF ANY ON ROLE.
THE BUDGET CAN BE IN WORKING
WITH STUDENTS WHO FOR THE ON.
OF FUTURE LEGAL ON. FUTURE
LEGAL AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THANK YOU. HI THIS IS POLICE
YEAH I THINK I HAVE FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON MINE I CAN TAKE
THE FIRST AT THIS QUESTION AND
WELL THERE. CONDITION
CONFERENCES WELL I'M- BOARD.
AND AS- AS ASSIST AS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE HAVE TRIED
DILIGENTLY TO. OUR AND- YOUTH
WHO ARE INVOLVED. THE COLLEGE'S
THEIR TENS OF OUR UNDOCUMENTED.
AND IN MANY THAT GOT. IN YOUR
BUDGET. A ON MANY OF. CURRENT
STUDENTS AND THE LARGER GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO WERE UNDOCUMENTED
AND CAME IS YOUNG PEOPLE AND
TREATED PROVIDE THEM WITH
PERMANENT RELIEF. ONLY CONGRESS
ON THAT ARE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
THE GOVERNMENT PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE AS I HAVE BEEN STRONG
ADVOCATES FOR AND THAT
PERMANENTLY ON THE ISSUE
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE I'M JUST
JUST YESTERDAY AFTERNOON. NEW
RANDOM RELATED TO THAT THE
SUPREME TO SAY ON THAT A GOING
TO ACT CORRECT ACCESS TO THE-
I'M GONNA GO FROM INTO YOUR
PROGRAM TO A ONE YEAR PROGRAM
BASICALLY. WHAT YOU HAVE TO.
YEAR I. IT'S GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE. OVER HERE TO HAVE.
AROUND JEFF RESTORE AND TO
APPLY DHAKA. IT INTO EFFORT AND
ALSO GET THE LEGAL SUPPORT THAT
YOU ALL. MAKES AFTER AND SO THE
FACT THAT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AROUND THE STATE ARE FIGHTING
THE SERVICES SUPPORTS AND THE
RECIPIENT. IT IS I. OR NIGHT.
THIS YEAR I THEIR- OR OF THOSE
LEGAL FOR. ON I WOULD SAY THAT
WE ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO SO
GOT STUDENTS ARTICLE IN
NINETEEN OUR CRISIS. AND AS
WELL AS SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
HERE IS ACT ARE THE CARE IS ON
THE PASSAGE YOU. ONCE YOU GO.
RIGHT RELIEF COLLEGE. WE'RE
ACTUALLY. HE DID FROM GETTING
ACCESS TO THAT CARE ACTUALLY
FINDING YOUR SOME TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION POLICIES WE
ADDRESS OF WHERE GOVERNOR'S AND
CHOSE TO TAKE ACTION- AND INTO
STILL- AT TWO O'CLOCK IN. AT
AND AS- A REGULAR. HARMFUL AT
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS TRYING
TO PURSUE AND ACTUALLY OUR ONE
OUR CASE IN COURT OUT AT WHICH
MEANS THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY THROUGH THE COLLEGES
RIGHT I CARES ACT FINDING AND-
YOU ARE AND I CAN YOUTH WHO ARE.
NEED THAT. A TO HELP THEM THIS
TIME I'M SO YOU KNOW ALWAYS I
THINK IT'S A BOY WILL CONTINUE
BE LOOKING FOR WAYS SUPPORT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND ALSO A CO
WORKER STORIES I WOULD KNOW.
WHERE I. AND A DOCUMENT STUDENT
AWARENESS WEEK AGAIN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS HAPPENED FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF. YEARS AND
LAST IN IN ALMOND EYES FIRST
WOULD MEETING ACTUALLY THE
BOARD APPROVED. AND I MAKING
THIS AND CELEBRATION WHERE WE
REALLY DO LOOK UP THE STORIES
OF THESE YOUNG. ARE AND- I. IN
TERMS OF REFORMS AND LEAD TO
RELIEF ACT TO PROVIDE AND MORE
AT TO THE DREAM SO I WILL I
WILL STOP THERE AND SEE IF MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT THINGS ACT I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE I
DOCUMENTS IF YOU. SPECIALLY THE
ONLY THING I LANDED AS A HUGE
PROPONENT. UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS THE AND THEY SHARE IN
PART BECAUSE I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS THE
CHAIR OF THE COALITION OF
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN LOS
ANGELES IT IS ONE AND THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT. RIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS FOCUS. AND
NATIONALLY WHO ADVOCATES FOR
THE NEEDS OF OUR IMMIGRANTS
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY ARE UNDOCUMENTED-
INDIVIDUALS AND STUDENTS. SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I CARE
VERY DEEPLY ABOUT MINE IS. AND
SO I DECIDED THAT. NOT ONLY A
CHANCE WAS OFFICE BUT THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS. HAVE BEEN HUGE
PROPONENTS OF ENSURING THAT WE
ARE BEING- KINDNESS OF THE
NEEDS OF ARE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND AS- I MENTIONED I
WILL RECAP ALL OF THE THINGS.
OR PLACED BUDGET. ONLINE SINCE
OF OUR. JUST THE YEAH MAKING
THAT WE ARE NEVER. OUR
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE I'M
DELIGHTED THAT THEM THE DREAMER
RESOURCE AND LIAISON. OR PART
OF THE- THAT IS GOING TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY WHERE WE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM ON TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE ADEQUATELY
IMPLEMENTING ON THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES AND
I'M MAKING SURE. OUR MINISTER
ARE. WHAT'S THANK. THANK YOU.
TERMINATE TO ADD- ADEQUATELY
COVERED NINE A VERY ADEQUATELY
COVERED THANKS THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM AND AGAIN THANK YOU TO
ALL CANDIDATES SOME BE
SUPPORTING YOU AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU. YOU
SENATE. EGGMAN PRO TEM- MEMBERS
CARILLO CELLS ARE MISTER CHAIR
CONGRATULATIONS YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY LAST YEAR.
SPEND A GOOD DEAL OF QUALITY
TIME WITH WITH THE CHAIR AND
SOME OF HIS COLLEAGUES ON A
VARIETY OF IS GOING TO DO WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGETS AND-
EIGHT TEN OVER ANY OF OTHERS.
SEN I TOSSED SOME PRETTY TOUGH
QUESTIONS SO. THAT YOU MISTER
CHAIR ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS AND-
I HAVE TO SAY THAT YOU HANDLE
EACH ONE OF THEM VERY WELL WITH
THE UP MOST. OF PROFESSIONALISM
STOP. THANK YOU I WILL. YOU
ANYMORE OF MY QUESTIONS AND
JUST PLEDGE TO WERE. WORK FOR
WORK WITH YOU TO FURTHER YOUR
AGENDA YOUR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES IN THE GOALS AND
ACTIVITIES OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR CONFIRMATIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU FOR TEN. THANK YOU BYE.
THANK YOU MAY OKAY TIONS TO ALL
OF YOU FOR YOUR POINT ARE
LOOKING FORWARD SUPPORTING YOU
WHEN THE TIME COMES I'VE GOT A
COUPLE JUST TO THE QUESTIONS OF
A START WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WANT. TO YOUR- CALIBRATE BUT
WAS NOT IN. IT WILL BE FOR
HEARD ABOUT AND CERTAINLY WE'VE
HAD A PRETTY POOR. AND SO JUST%
INTERESTED ON YOUR VISION FOR
THAT AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THAT BACK ON TRACK HOPEFULLY.
THANK THANKS QUESTION AND I'M I
AM. I'VE BEEN CHAIR THE
CALIBRATE BOARD SINCE IT
LAUNCHED AND IT'S- IT'S BEEN
VERY CHALLENGING. HE AND WE
UNFORTUNATELY THE INITIAL
LEADERSHIP DID NOT ACHIEVE ALL
HE WANTED TO ACHIEVE AND- BUT
WE HAVE A NEW TEAM IN PLACE NOW
THAT IS THAT IS MAKING A LOT OF
PRESS VERY QUICKLY. AND SAYING
IT'S I THINK IT'S REALLY MOST
IMPORTANT CALIBRATE IS THAT IT
REALLY DOES OFFER A UNIQUE
SERVICE IT'S NOT OFFERED AMONG
OUR OTHER. COLLEGES IT. I DON'T
SEE DAIS EDUCATION MODEL THAT
THEY USE IS NOT REPLICATED
ANYWHERE. IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND- THE- IT'S
NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER- AS
SOFT AS THEIR NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
UNEMPLOYED. AND EVERYBODY'S
BEEN FORCED TO GO ONLINE AND
THAT'S WHAT COUNTY WAS
PRECISELY DESIGNED FOR WAS TO
HELP PEOPLE THAT ARE THEY NEED
TO GET A FEW A LITTLE
ADDITIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND MORE
SKILLS WITHOUT THE ECONOMIC
LADDER. AND IT'S BEEN. GREAT
THROUGH AND I THINK WE'VE WE'VE
TURNED THE CORNER ON. LINE I.
MAKE DISTANCE IF YOU ENTER CAN-
CAN PROGRESS AND ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS- I AM. YOU KNOW I DO AND
I. HAS ALSO SAY THAT THE OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DO A GREAT
JOB OF- OF THIS KIND OF CAREER
TRAINING BUT THEY DO IT JUST IN
A DIFFERENT WAY FOR THE ALMOST.
COMPLETE I AN S. AND- ANY
THOUGH BUT YOU KNOW THERE IS AN
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE
AMONG THE ALL THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- ONLY HALF OF THEM
EVEN PARTICIPATE IN IT
LEGISLATURE FUNDED OUT SEVERAL
ON OUR- BUT HALF THE COLLEGES
DON'T EVEN BREAK PARTICIPATE IN
THAT AND SO. THE COLLEGES HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO TO BECOME-
REALLY- THE CHRISTIAN AND AN
ONLINE EDUCATION AND HELP
RIGHT. WE WERE THE ENDEAVOR TO
I'M NEW GROUND DEVELOP NEW
TECHNIQUES THAT. IT WILL THEN
BE SURE TO THE OTHER COLLEGES
IN FACT CALIBER OUR-
PARTNERSHIP. TO THE MANY
COLLEGES ONE IN. AND ONE ON. SO
WHAT MORE THAN. AS CALIBRATE
PLOWS IS BROWN AND DEVELOPS NEW
WAYS DOING THAT- WE CAN SHARE
THAT KNOWLEDGE OF THE OTHER
COLLEGES AND THAT THEY CAN-
THEY CAN GAIN FROM THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND OFF. IN BACK
ONLINE PROGRAMS AND COMPETENCY
BASED PROGRAMS WHICH I KNOW IN
IN- IN THE CHAIRS. DISTRICT THE
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT IS AMONG THE
LEADERS IN THAT THING. GREATER
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
SO- DOCTORS ALSO QUESTION FOR
YOU SO YOUR BACKGROUND IS YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY- IN THE POLICY
AREAS SO A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO
WITH BUSINESS TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. AREAS YOUR VIEW IN
TERMS OF HOW WELL- THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS INTERACTS WITH AND
PLANTS WITH OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IT AS IT RELATES TO
THOSE ISSUES PROJECT WITH
ENDEMIC COMING BACK THREE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE RETRAINED
AND RE EQUIPPING A LOT MORE
STUDENTS MY GAS HAS. BEEN OUR-
I THINK THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
I MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ADVOCATING FOR. YOU KNOW
AFFECTSTHE AROUND THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. THAT I
THINK ARE IN TROUBLE TO
ENSURING THAT WE ARE PROVIDING.
ACCESS TO THOSE SHORT TERM
CREDENTIALS WHERE STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO CAREER PATHWAYS
PARTICULARLY IN THIS TIME.
THERE ARE CERTAIN- INDUSTRY
PATHWAYS ARE THAT ARE IN NEED
OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS- SO I YOU
KNOW I THINK WE HAVE FOLLOWED
VERY CLOSELY ON THE-
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
EFFORTS- I THINK THERE'S A- IN
THIS THAT I AM. AGAIN AS A
WORKFORCE PERSON- I DEEPLY CARE
ABOUT. THERE'S DEFINITELY MORE
AND THAT CAN BE DONE AND I'M
HAPPY TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS. TO
ENSURE THAT THAT THAT IS YEAH.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT AGAIN
UP. QUESTIONS TO ALL OF YOU I.
MY FAVORITE HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTE IN THE STATE IS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- I WENT TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE A COULD HAVE
NOT GONE THROUGH SCHOOL WITHOUT
IT IN A WAS HAD THE HONOR
SERVING SIX YEARS BOARD OF
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS. IN ONE
CALIFORNIA SO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE. YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO ADD MY
THANKS FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK
AND PARTICULARLY. TO THE
CHAIRMAN WHO. IS VERY GOOD AT
REACHING OUT AND KEEP ME POSTED
ON ACTIVITY. FROM THE BOARD'S
PERSPECTIVE AS THE PRO TEM
IDEA. COULDN'T ASK FOR A BETTER.
THE RELATIONSHIP IN WHICH YOU
DO THE OUTRAGE AND I KNOW YOU
DO THAT ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS BUT I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION I AM
VERY PROUD OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THANK YOU FOR
REFERENCING DIEGO. BUT I THINK
THIS IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT OUR STATE OF. THE KIND OF
LEADERSHIP OUR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM SO I WANNA I
WANT TO LEND MY THANKS TO ALL
OF YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS TO.
YOU ARE UP THESE ARE AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ASKED
THE QUESTIONS AND I DO THINK
PROBABLY THE CHAIRED A BUDGET
OF WHAT I. FOR IN A- HE AND ALL
OF THESE IT. IS I'M GONNA TURN
TO ME OF THE I THINK I HAVEN'T
ANYTHING SO- WITH THAT WE WILL
START WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND SEEING NONE I
WILL. I LOOK AND MAKE SURE WE
HAVE NO ONE WAITING TO SPEAK IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE OKAY WITH THAT
I WILL TURN TO OUR MODERATOR
FOR THE TELL CONFERENCE. WE
WILL. FALLS SUPPORT SOME
MODERATOR. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END THERE NOW AGAIN HE SHOWS
THE- PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE HAVE THREE AND THEY KILL
GLOBAL TIMELINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M NOT A LOT OF THE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AS
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
DOCTOR ON MY SALAD BARS
APPOINTMENT TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BOARD OF GOVERNORS I'M
NOT CURRENTLY SERVES AS A BOARD
MEMBER FOR AGENCIES TRULY AN
INSPIRATION NOT ONLY TO ME BUT
ALSO TO WORK. THANK COUNTLESS.
CONOR OVER THE HER WORK IN
HELPING UNDERSERVED THRIVE IN
OUR ECONOMY HER HE'S AN
INVALUABLE INSIGHT ON EDUCATION
AND WORKFORCE ABOUT POLICY HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS ASSET TO OUR
EDGE TEAM AND I KNOW SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN ACTOR FOR THE
UNITY COLLEGE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND RESPECTFULLY YOUR
SUPPORT. ASK YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
AXOLOTL NINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MARIE JOHNSON
WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF ALL THREE CANDIDATES
APPOINTMENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS ALL THREE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT TO
KEEPING. IT IS THAT THE
PRIORITY AFTER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SUPPORTING
STUDENTS TO CREATE A BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES AND THE
STATE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
EXTRA GRATITUDE FOR ALMOST ALL
DARK HUNTER MADE ACCESSIBLE TO
STAY COLD HERE THE MEMBERS. WE
ARE YOU CREATION FOR ALL CAN AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WHAT.
MAX LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE PROVIDE.
LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN WELCOME.
JEFF CARTER YEAR GOOD SUPPORT
BUT I WOULD ASK THE CHAIR COULD
YOU ASK THE QUESTION. CRITICS
IS BACK TO BE BUDGET IS
REDUCING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING. THE NEXT YEAR. WHAT IS
THE LIKELY. I WANT TO SHOW
PLANS WE ARTICLE BUT NINETEEN
WE NEED TO BE PUT IN PLACE.
BECAUSE EACH YOU HAVE THEY
CRIED LAYER AND KNOWING THE%
COMMUTER COLLEGE UNDER PLACE SO
MUCH OF OUR WORK. AND WITH OUR
WORKFORCE. SO ATARI JOB THIRTY
IN EFFORTS NEED TO BE VERY WHAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THANK
YOU I WILL I AND YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT LET ME CLARIFY. YES
OKAY THANK YOU- I IN DE IT THE
END I WILL SEE IF. ARE ANY OF
THE APPOINTEES WANT TO COMMENT
OR IF MY COLLEAGUES WANT TO-
HAVE THAT QUESTOR ANSWERED
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. AND AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT IT'S THE WIND THEN
THEY'RE ALL AGAIN LONDON ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
AT THE MOMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE WE WILL RETURN AND GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION. I AND LET ME START
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE SEEING NO ONE HERE FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. LET ME
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OKAY I SEE NO ONE THERE
TO SPEAK MADAME MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO MAY BE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU
DO YOU WISH TO UPHOLD PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN
TO OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE AND Q. AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MADE A
MODERATOR LET ME- SEE IF I ANY
OF THE APPOINTEES WANNA MAKE
ANY CONCLUDING COMMENTS
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF A-
QUESTION FROM A MEMBER THE
PUBLIC YOU. DO NOT NEED TO
DISCUSSION HAS CEASED BUT I
WOULD GIVE YOU THAT OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY LET ME RETURN TO MY
COLLEAGUES I DIDN'T I KEEP
TRACK OF WHICH THANK YOU I KNOW
I DIDN'T GET THE PRECURSOR I
USUALLY GET ON I DID I MISS
OKAY- SENATOR ROTH HAS MADE THE
MOTION FOR ALL THREE I'M
ASSUMING WE DO NOT NEED TO
SEPARATE. SO THE MOTION I IS TO
APPOINT. THE CONFEREES IN FRONT
OF US TODAY MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL. MINING
AYE MONNING AYE ROTH AYE ROTH
AYE WILK RIGHT LOOK I ATKINS
AYE ATKINS AYE. CONGRATULATIONS
TO EACH OF YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A SHORT BREAK SO THE ARE WELL
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A SHORT BREAK
SO WE'LL BE BACK IN FIVE
MINUTES THANK YOU.
STARTED
RECONVENE I WE WILL START AS
SOON AS OUR VICE CHAIRMAN IS
BACK BUT I WANTED TO PUT FOCUS
ON NOTICE.
OKAY WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND- CALL THE MEETING
BACK TO ORDER. AND LET ME
INTRODUCE OUR- THE MEMBERS ARE
THE OUR APPOINTMENTS AND
COMMISSIONERS WHO ARE HERE FOR
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
THAT WOULD BE- MISS MARIA GOOD
TERRACE. MS DEBORAH SAN JUAN
AND I MISS MERRY THORTON JD LET
ME SAY WELCOME. AND I INVITE I
EACH OF YOU TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES- WELCOME ANYONE OUR
ARMED THANK ANYWAY I'M SORRY
THANK ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THEN
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS WILL
GO- WANTED TIME STARTING WITH
MS GOOD TERRACE. THEN IT IS SAN
JUAN AND MISS THORTON AND THEN
WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMON QUESTIONS
SO WITH THAT MISCUETERRACE
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN WAITING. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE BEFORE
YOU CAN NAME AGAIN MY NAME'S
WHERE YOU GET TERRACE AND I
HAVE SERVED AS A PUBLIC
SERVANT. OVER THIRTY FOUR YEARS
ALONG. YOU'RE ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAREER I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN SEVERAL
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO
EXPERIENCED NUMEROUS PURPOSEFUL
ASSIGNMENTS THAT EVENTUALLY
HELP ME YOUR RISE IN THE RANKS
OF MY ORGANIZATION. AND TO
HIGHLIGHT TO SPECIFIC ROLES AS
THEY RELATE TO MY CURRENT
POSITION INCLUDED BEING A
CAPTAIN ARE ALSO KNOWN AS A
WARDEN. ONE OF THE LARGEST
FEMALE CUSTODIAL FACILITIES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND IN THE
COUNTRY. THIS WILL OPEN MY EYES
TO ALL OF THE INTRICACIES ARE
WILL BE PARKED WITHIN A- STILL.
MENTAL HEALTH MEDICAL
PROGRAMMING STAGE THE- BUDGET
EXCEPT TRACKS YEAH AND IT ALL
PROVIDE ME WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT SEVERAL PRISONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IN ORDER TO COMPARE
CHALLENGES IDEAS ARE SYSTEMS AT
ONE PLACE. I ALSO HAD THE GOOD
FORTUNE TO HAVE THE ROLE OF
CHIEF FOR THE COURTS SERVICES
DIVISION OF OUR ORGANIZATION.
THIS WAS AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE
DOESN'T ALLOW ME TO MANAGE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERVICES FOR THIRTY
EIGHT INITIAL. OR HOUSES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY. AREAS TO
THE WORLD. AND I THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE AND PER
PURPOSEFUL NEXT CHAPTER IN MY
LIFE. WHAT YOU WOULD ALLOW ME
TO CONTINUE TO UTILIZE THE
WONDERFUL TOOLS AND KNOWLEDGE
THAT THEY GAIN THROUGHOUT MY
PRIOR PROFESSION. SO MICHAEL
THIS MY GOAL IS TO BUILD AN
EXPERTISE IN THIS ROLE THAT
WILL ALLOW ME TO ADD VALUE WHAT
ALWAYS PRESERVING PUBLIC SAFETY
INSURANCE IN PROCESS TO EVERY
OFFENDER WHO COMES UNDER THE
BOARD'S JURISDICTION. SO I WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT AND ALSO THANK YOU
FOR INVESTING YOUR TIME AND FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY. I AM
SUPPORTED BY MY FAMILY WERE NOT
AVAILABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN A
THEY ARE VERY EXCITED FOR ME
NOT ALWAYS SUPPORTED. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS HAVE YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISS WHAT. GO AHEAD IF.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE GOVERNOR'S NEW SUMMER
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. HER TODAY
I'M HERE WITH MY HUSBAND WHO
WAS SITTING NEXT TO ME AND I
HAVE MANY FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS MY TWO CHILDREN MY
MOTHER WHO ARE ALL WATCHING A
LIVE STREAM. I HAVE BEEN
PREPARING FOR THIS APPOINTMENT
FOR THE PAST FORTY YEARS FROM
EARNING DEGREES SENTIMENT OF
ELEMENT IN SOCIAL WORK AND
HAVING COLLEGE INTERNSHIP TO
THE PROBATION AND IN THE US THE
FORTY. THEN I HAD AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR CAREER IN THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH AUTHORITY INCLUDING SEVEN
YEARS WRITING CYCLE SOCIAL
EVALUATION. AND THE YOUTH
AUTHORITY AND I TEN YEARS
SUPERVISING ADOLESCENT SEX
OFFENDER TREATMENT PROGRAM. I
THEN MOVED ON TO ADULT PAROLE
WORRY SPENT THE FOLLOWING
ELEVEN YEARS AND THE LAST FIVE
YEARS OF. OF MY TIME IN CORAL I
WAS OF THE NORTH BAY DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATOR. I RETIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AFTER
HAVING A TWENTY EIGHT YEAR
CAREER. FOLLOWING RETIREMENT. I
BEGAN WORKING AS A MEDICAL
SOCIAL WORKER IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM OF A HOSPITAL IN VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA DURING THAT TIME I
ALSO ARE IN THE HOURS. AND TOOK
THE TEST TO BECOME A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER. TO
IDEALS THAT I'VE CARRIED WITH
ME THROUGHOUT MY CAREER- ONE IN
THE YOUTH AUTHORITY IT WAS WHEN
WE WROTE VALUES AND THAT WAS
THE PEOPLE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GROW AND CHANGE. AND THEN IN
THE CROATIAN ACADEMY WHICH I-
WENT THROUGH A TWO THOUSAND
SIX- WE A CAPTAIN OF ON US THAT
THE BEST RELATED WHAT SOMEONE
WHO IS 50% COPY A 50% SOCIAL
WORKER. AND I THINK I USE THOSE
IDEALS- IN THE PAST NINE MONTHS
THAT I'VE BEEN A COMMISSIONER
ON THE FORWARD. I AGAIN WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND- I AM AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH I MISS
THORTON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE AND THANK MY FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO ARE JOURNAL ONLINE
TODAY. FIRST MY HUSBAND PETER
WALL AND ALSO MY PARENTS'
CURTAIN JEANINE THORNTON. PRIOR
TO SERVING AS A COMMISSIONER
FOR THE BORDER PRO HEARINGS MY
CAREER HAS GIVEN ME UNIQUE
EXPERIENCES AND NOW ENHANCE MY
SERVING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THIS NEW WAY. MY CAREER
BEGAN APPROXIMATELY WITH THE
DECADES SERVING AS A PROSECUTOR
FIRST AS AN INTERN IN THE US
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE DURING MY
FINAL YEAR OF LAW SCHOOL.
PROSECUTING FEDERAL MISDEMEANOR
CRIMES IN THIS THE DEATH DE
ATTORNEY FOR BOTH MADERA IN
KINGS COUNTY. PROSECUTING A
VARIETY OF CRIMES. ALL THE WAY
FROM DO YOU ICE TO MURDER IN
WERE. CORRECT STERN. I'LL HAVE
AS A DE COMMISSIONER OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF PRIOR TO MY AND
ALLOWED ME TO GET FAMILIAR WITH
THE HEARINGS TO BE INVOLVED IN
THOSE HEARINGS AS WELL AS
WITNESSED FIRST HAND PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN REHABILITATED EVEN
AFTER A LENGTHY HISTORY OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR MY GOAL WAS A
COMMISSIONER INCLUDES TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE JUSTICE AS
A- UNITY I. PASSED TO THE TERM
INMATES CONTINUE TO POST ON
RESTORE RESTORE PUBLIC SAFETY
IN WHICH OF THOSE HAS OFFICIALS
REPEAT AND NO LONGER PERCENT
THAT YOUR WAY. AND ALSO TO BE
FAIR AND- EVERYONE WILL THIS IF
YOU LOOK FOR TO YOUR QUESTIONS
DO YOU HAVE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
GO TO SENATOR BATES OUR FIRST
SENATOR RATES. I'M I'M UNIT YOU
HEAR ME I CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
HELLO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ATKINS
AND- LET ME CONGRATULATE ALL
THREE OF YOU FOR STEPPING UP ON
TAKE THIS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BUT VERY CHALLENGING ROLE ON
OUR- OUR BOARD OF. ARE CRUEL
WORKED VERY VERY AYE DIFFICULT
AT TIMES I'M SURE CAN BE
EMOTIONAL OUT FROM BOTH SIDES
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR DOWN I'M
GONNA START WITH THE QUESTION
WELL FOR. A NEW SOUND WINE.
LAST YEAR I ACTUALLY HAVING TO
BE. THAT WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR SB ONE FORTY ONE WHICH
REQUIRES AN ADDITIONAL
ASSESSMENT. RISK ASSESSMENT
FOR. THE VIOLENCE. OF YOURS AND
I KNOW THIS IS A PARTICULAR
THAT YOU HAVE FOCUSED ON SOME
OF YOUR FINANCE ON DURING THE
RULES INTERVIEW AND I WAS
WONDERING HOW YOU VIEW THIS.
ADDITIONAL ARE REALLY FAST
PERCEPTUAL BUYER ANDERSON HOW.
WOULD WHERE SHE- YOU SURE
EXPERIENCE THIS NEW TRACK ALL
AS YOU WILL WAIT CHILD THE
REQUEST FOR PAROLE FOR
SOMETHING SENATE. AND IS A HUGE.
CONCERN IN OUR COMMUNITY SAID
SHE NO WAY VIOLENT SEX
OFFENDERS ARE PAROLED THERE'S
USUALLY A BIT OF A PROBLEM S.
AS THEY COME OUT INTO COMMUNITY
HELLO. BUT MERE THOUGHT THAT.
FROM THE- BUT THEY SPEAKING TO
I I'M FAMILIAR WITH BUT I AM
FAMILIAR WITH SEVERAL
ASSESSMENTS FOR SEX OFFENDERS
AND- I DO REVIEW THE IS THAT
THE FRANTIC PSYCHOLOGIST RIGHT
RIGHT IN THE COMPREHENSIVE RISK
ASSESSMENT. I AM NOT SURE WHAT
ELSE I DO NOT FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT YOU'RE SPECIFICALLY
SPEAKING TO. FIVE WITHOUT
SAYING SO THAT FOR PROBABLY
SOMETHING ELSE I HAVE TO FOLLOW
AFTER. AFTER TODAY'S HEARING
BECAUSE IT WAS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN IT WAS A
SPECIFIC REQUEST BY OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS THAT WOULD
WE HAVE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
OFFENDERS THAT THERE IS. A
SUPPLEMENTAL RISK ASSESSMENT RE
OFFENDING OUR WITH OUR YOU KNOW
AND SEX OFFENDER FOR SEXUAL
CRIMES. THE WE- BELIEVER AT
COLIN THE- AND THEY DON'T COME
OUT OF THEM SO WE WOULD NOT SEE
THEM PART OF OUR WORLD. A LIVE
OPS AND- THERE WAS WAS SO
SUPPOSED. NOT NECESSARILY
CORRECT ON HIGH WHERE THE
CLIENTS THAT WE CAN FOLLOW UP
ON THAT I THINK THAT YOUR
COMMENTS DURING THE HEARING.
THAT TO YOU DON'T COME INTO IT
HERE THE BELIEVE THAT ONCE A
SEX OFFENDER IS. A SEX OFFENDER
ARMY BECAUSE ONE IS GOT. TO
MENTION OUR SOMETIMES THAT HAS
SICKLY ON USER. I GUESS MICHAEL
MET HE IS MORE CIVIC IS ABOUT
YOU SEE THE BY. THE VENDORS AND
I THINK THOSE ARE THE THAT ARE
A MOST CONCERN ANGRY RISK WHEN
NAY RE ENTERED THE COMMUNITY
VERSUS SOME OF THOSE WHO ARE
ALL LESSER ON CRIME. THANK OF
YEAH SHARE SOME OF THAT OPTION
IN TERMS OF HOW VALUE THOSE.
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT A VIOLENT
SEX OFFENDER MUCH BE GIVEN MUCH
MORE SCRUTINY AND- WHEN WE'RE
WHEN WE ARE. DURING THE
HEARINGS. WE DO AS WE LOOK AT
THEIR HISTORY OF VIOLENCE WE
LOOK AT THE VIOLENCE. THAT THEY
COMMITTED AND THEY'RE BLACK
CRIME OR THE CRIME THAT- HAS
SENT THEM TO PRISON. HI TALK TO
THE OFFENDER OR ABOUT WHAT WAS
THROUGH YOUR MIND WHAT WERE YOU
THINKING WHEN YOU DID THAT BACK
THEN WHAT WERE YOUR- REASONS
FOR DOING THAT AND THEN. THAT
WITH. HOW THEY CHANGED. TODAY I.
HOW DO THEY VIEW THE CRIME
TODAY THAT THEY DID USUALLY
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS AGO AND-
THEN WE ALSO LOOK AT THE
HISTORY AND PRESENT THEY
CONTINUE TO ACT THEY CONTINUE
TO ACT VIOLENT SEVERAL
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION AND I ALSO
WANT TO MENTION THAT THE
COMPREHENSIVE RISK ASSESSMENT
WE PLAYEDCLOSE ATTENTION TO.
COLLEGES SAYS RIGHT THEM THAT'S
A LOW ARE HIRING FOR BUYOUT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWERING
YOU'VE GIVEN ME THE PATHWAY SO
I COULD FOLLOW UP ON NOW WHERE
AN SB ONE FORTY ONE IS BEING
APPLIED AND HOW IDEAS IN TERMS
OF. INTERVIEWS SO BORED OUT OF
SEXUALLY VIOLENT YEARS BECAUSE
IT. HAS PRESENTED TO ME AND WE
AUTHORED IT WAS SEX JERRY.
REQUIREMENTS HOW THAT YOU RISK
ASSESSED THAT'S DONE. THANK YOU
THIS AND ONE QUESTION FOR MR
TEAR US. IF YOU DON'T MIND ME
JUST AT A TO WHAT THAT OF
DECEMBER ONE JUST MENTION
REGARD. THE SEX OF. THERE IS A
FULL STATIC NINETY NINE WE IS
MENTIONED IN THE COPPER. RISK
ASSESSMENT THE DOES HE VALUE
WAIT A SEX OFFENDERS- YOU NO
CHANCE FOR WE ARE. COMMITTING
ANOTHER CRIME AND SO NO ONE
WOULD BE RELEASED IF THERE
SHOULD BE ANY CURRENT THREAT TO
THE PUBLIC BUT THAT TOOL. IN
THE COMPREHENSIVE. OF I BELIEVE
THAT THAT EXACTLY WHAT RELATED
TO THE BILL YOU WERE MAY. IT'S
POSSIBLY AS POSSIBLE THAT IT IS
BETTER YOU KNOW. PLEASE STAND
TO WHAT YOU CURRENTLY DO RATHER
THAN IT BEING SENT A SEPARATE
TRIED TOOL VERY POSSIBLY BUT I
WILL I WILL FOLLOW UP ON THAT
THANK YOU. YOUR MISS THE
TERRACE- QUESTION. IN THIS
HOUSE TO DO WITH THE ABILITY OF
ON THE VICTIMS SIDE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARINGS. I
HEARD THERE WAS DIFFICULTY USE
UP FOR THE VICTIMS
PARTICIPATING IN A HEARING
RECENTLY AND I WONDERED IF. YOU
IF YOU ARE. THAT WITH BOB COMES
TESTIMONY IS AN ACCURATE THAT
SOME OF THE TOP NO ACTUALLY I.
THE GOAL WHAT A QUICK MINUTE
NOT WORKING OUT TO THEIR
ADVANTAGE AND THE OF SOUL EYES
ANYTHING BEING ADDRESSED ABOUT
SINCE THIS I GUESS IT'S
HAPPENED WHEN MORE OF THESE ARE
ALL CERTAINLY HAD A GUEST. YES
THANK YOU ARE I. YEAH THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'RE USING NOW
WITH VIDEO CONFERENCING I FEEL
IS TO THE CONTRARY ACTUALLY
HELPING VICTIMS COME ONLINE AND
MARK YOU CASH. ACTIVE SOMETIMES
ARE BLACK OR OTHERS. AND NOW
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TRAVEL
ANYMORE WHICH I FIND TO BE MUCH
MORE EASY IT'S EASIER FOR THEM
AND NOW THEY EVEN HAVE THE
OPTION OF BEING ON AUDIO. ON
VIDEO CHOOSE THE SELF THEY HAVE
OPTIONS BUT WHEN THEY DO COME
ONLINE AFTER HEARING. BECAUSE
WE HAVE NOT. TO SPEAK TO THEM
AND PRIVATE BEFORE WE EVEN BE
THE HEARING. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND WILL HAPPEN.
ARE WE TRYING TO TAKE ALL THE
MYSTERY OUT OF IT SO THAT THEY
FEEL COMFORTABLE AND PIANO THEM
ALL THE TIME THAT THEY TO SPEAK
WHEN THEY MAKE. THEIR IMPACT
STATEMENT SO. REALLY ALSO OF
THE- BUT A SPECIAL TO OUR
VACANCY THE TIME TO COME I'M
COURTS NAME OPEN THEIR HOME
THAT'S IN TO ME THEM IS AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU THAT'S GOOD
TO HEAR AND PERHAPS I WAS JUST
A ONE TIME OCCURRENCE OR A
COUPLE TIMES WE'VE HAD. OUR OWN
LITTLE ISSUES AT TIMES WITHOUT
SOME OF THE TELECONFERENCING
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING A FINAL
QUESTION FROM MISFORTUNE
ANYTHING ON JOHN AND ALL OF YOU
ARE CERTAINLY. OPEN TO GIVE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE US I
WONDERED HAVE YOU HAD ANY
PARTICIPATION. THE I'M NOT. OF
THE RESET REAL OF LOS. HUNDRED
OF. A INDIVIDUALS ARE EARLY
RELEASE WELL NOW THAT HAS TO BE
AND NOW SET BY THE GOVERNOR HE
BEAT ME IS THERE ANY
PARTICIPATION- BY THE MEASURES
ON THE COLD RECORD WITH ANY ONE
OF THESE RELEASES OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S DONE MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE LATE. I KNOW
NEAR RISK REVIEW SAYS THAT WILL
BE STARTING AND SOME CAN
PERSONALLY TAKING PART I MEAN
THIS YEAH IT'S GOING TO BE.
QUITE BUT I AM NOT. HARD. ABOUT
THE COMMENT ABOUT THEM SO ONE
OF UPS WITH HEARINGS WAY WE
VICTIMS IS I HAD A RECENT THERE
WERE OR TWO THE ONLY MEMBERS OF
THE VICTIMS WHO WERE PRESS IN
BECAUSE THEY WERE. IN THE A LOT
OF TO BE TOGETHER. A MORE ONE
OF OUR OTHER OTHER WORDS ARE
ROOMS TEND TO VERY SO. AND SO
OFTEN IF YOU HAVE OR TWELVE
MEMBERS AND THERE IS THERE
LITERALLY YOU TO BE ON ON TOP
OF EACH OTHER IN THEN THE
INMATE HAS A TRAIN WILL BE
THERE AS WELL AS THIS MORE
COMFORTABLE. OTHER AT YOU ONE
OF. TRANSACTION IT WAS CLEAR
THEY WERE COMFORT TO ME OTHER
IN IT WAS THE MORE EFFECTIVE I
THOUGHT FOR THEM GO THROUGH
THIS IN BE A JUST OF EACH THE
PROCESS IT'S A VERY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE AS MUCH AS IT COULD
BE FOR THAT TIME. AND I THINK
IT'S PROBABLY IN ONE OR TWO
WHERE THAT MIGHT HAPPEN BUT
THAT'S REALLY GREAT YEAR TO
THAT YOU ACCOMMODATED THAT SO
WITHOUT I THINK THAT COVERS
WHAT I WANTED CHEN ON ASK YOU
SLIP AGAIN FOR YOU THANK YOU
RESPOND AS I'LL BE DOING LOT
MORE REVIEW. NOT A SEXUALLY
VIOLENT ISSUE I AND BE BACK TO
YOU WHEN YOU COME UP FOR
CONFIRMATION. DURING OUR- SO
THEY AGAIN. AND HERE SATURDAY
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I DID HAVE A
CHANCE TO TALK TO EACH OF THE
APPOINTEES I WANT TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THEIR RESPECTIVE
SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK THEM. XIN
OFFER STEPPING UP TO TAKE ON
THIS WORK. MY QUESTION WAS
GONNA GO TO THE USE OF VIDEO
HEARINGS IN AND HOW VICTIMS
FAMILIES ARE ACCOMMODATED- YOU
DRESS THOSE WHEN I SPOKE WITH
YOU ON THE PHONE AND AGAIN AN
OPPORTUNITY IN RESPONSE TO
SENATOR BATES QUESTIONS SO I
HAVE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME I'LL BE SUPPORTING
CONFIRMATIONS AND I THINK YOU
EACH AN OFFER YOUR SERVICE.
PEOPLE FORMULA THANK YOU. THERE
LET ME TURN TO MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL THREE OF
YOU- MY QUESTIONS WERE ALONG
THE LINE OF SENATOR BASE WHICH
WAS ADDRESSED SO AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS FOR SUPPORTING
YOUR MISSION. THANK YOU YOU.
SENATOR ROTH THE MAN APPROACHED
HIM NO QUESTIONS SIR
CONGRATULATIONS AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU SENATOR ROOM HERE. THANK
YOU ARE WE ARE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND AT THIS TIME GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC EYE I'M
GONNA GIVE A REMINDER TO
WITNESSES WISHING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT IT'S BEEN AWHILE SINCE
I MENTIONED THAT TO SPIT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. WHICH IS.
844-291-6364 IT'S ON THE SCREEN
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE ONE
SEVEN SEVEN TWO NINE TWO. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE. ONE ONE SEVEN SEVEN TWO
NINE TWO. WE WILL START HERE
WITH WITNESSES IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO SPEAK
THIS IS FOR SUPPORT BY THE WAY-
LET ME GO AHEAD AND LOOK IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO ONE THERE. THERE IS
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO
I'M GOING TO TURN TO OUR
MODERATOR. AND I ASK FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC BY
TELECONFERENCE CALL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MINIMIZE RAIDER. SURE AND I
FEEL LIKE TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS THE WINDS AND BERYL AGAIN
HE SHOWS THE COURT PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q. AT THE
MOMENT. OKAY LET'S GIVE IT
ANOTHER THIRTY SECONDS. MADAME
MODERATOR WE CHECK ONE LAST
TIME. SURE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FERAL AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE
DO NOT SHOW ANYONE THANK YOU AT
THE MOMENT OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE GONNA COME BACK INTO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND
AGAIN THERE ARE NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION LET ME JUST DOUBLE
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEEING
NO ONE STEP FORWARD MADAME
MODERATOR LET ME COME BACK TO
YOU TO SEE IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE. WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SURE
AND IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS THE WINDS AND
THEIR OWN NOW. AGAIN HELLO
POLLS. ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL NOW.
I DO NOT SHOW ANYONE AND YOU AT
THE MOMENT. META MODERATOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP TODAY
WE SO APPRECIATE ANA WE SO
APPRECIATE IT SO THANK YOU. LET
ME GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ASK DO WE NEED A
SEPARATE MOTION ARE CAN WE DO
ONE MOTION. OKAY I SENATOR ROTH
I THINK DENTURE Q. MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MONNING AYE WANTING AYE
ROTH AYE ROTH AYE WILK RIGHT. I
ATKINS I CAN SIGN
CONGRATULATIONS THAT IS FOUR
ZERO WITH MISS BATES NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY FOR SURE.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU EVERYONE.
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO GO AYE AYE
NEGLECTED AND COULD HAVE DONE
THIS EARLIER WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. WE HAVE
ITEMS H. THROUGH W. AND I DON'T
KNOW IF I NEED TO PULL ANYONE
OUT OR WE CAN TAKE ONE MOTION
SO MOVED THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN ART MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THANK AYE
MONNING AYE ROTH- ROTH AYE WILK
HI LOOK I ATKINS HI ATKINS I.
THAT IS WONDERFUL ITEM TO H.
THROUGH W. HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH FOUR ZERO OUT WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION.